con reivindicaciones como esta los
trabajadores de Francia salieron a las
calles para pedir dos cosas en concreto
una subida salarial y mejores
condiciones en las pensiones
cuando los precios suben los salarios
bajos disminuyen aún más y los problemas
de poder adquisitivo se agudizan llegar
a fin de meses cada vez más difícil para
más familias en Francia eso es lo que
hay que solucionar los padres han sido
convocados por algunos sindicatos
franceses tras meses de huelgas en
sectores como el transporte y la
educación y el de la energía que está en
huelga en paralelo a las marchas algo
que ha preocupado al gobierno tras el
recorte la producción de energía nuclear
en medio de la crisis de abastecimiento
en toda Europa
queremos que la energía la electricidad
y el gas dejan de estar en manos de los
accionistas porque creemos que es una
necesidad básica para que cualquier
ciudadano pueda calentar su casa y
utilizar la electricidad el precio
razonable
ahora en medio del aumento de la
inflación y del costo de vida el
gobierno de macon pretende aumentar la
edad legal para jubilarse una medida que
enfrenta una gran oposición y que
incrementaría el malestar social no
obstante el presidente ya insinuado la
posibilidad de convocar elecciones
anticipadas si su reforma de pensiones
no sale adelante